[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this Canadian industry study finds one
you mean lights too
[Music]
No
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
it's really simple I just went away toy
Canadian Jerris Loski was born in
Oakville Canada on June 24th 1996 and
from a young age it was clear that
Canadian didn't just like competition he
lived for it I guess I am just I've
always been a competitive person so like
when I did play those sports I just
always wanted to win always wanted to be
better and stuff like that on top of
trying to get the best grades and beat
his brother at video games Canadian
demonstrated a natural affinity for
sport and spent most of his childhood
engaged in physical competition
I played triple-a which was like the
highest at the time where I could play
so I played with like other NHL errs
like I played with Mitch Marner and
played with like some other people that
are in the NHL whatnot yeah of all the
sports he excelled in hockey was the one
he held dearest but it was also the one
that would prove the most destructive by
13 he suffered nearly a dozen
concussions and was barred from engaging
even the most basic forms of physical
activity he'd gone from a kid who
dreamed of being a professional athlete
to one who wasn't even allowed to ride a
bicycle you couldn't ride a bike and to
refine yourself and there's no quick
method
how do you feel unable to manifest his
competitiveness physically Canadian
turned his attention to gaming I
remember when you first started and it
was you know out of nowhere yeah
Nathan needed something competitive to
do and that was like what I really found
I guess then in 2015 he set his sights
on Ubisoft zuly released tactical
shooter Rainbow six siege boasting
strategic depth dense mechanics in a
savage time to kill it seemed like a
perfect fit for a competitor as fierce
and as intense as Canadian Call of Duty
wasn't it was very fast-paced more
running gun not as strategy focused in
csgo was more strategy focused but I was
so far behind in it so siege was kind of
brand-new very focused on the strategy
and teamwork and all that and less so
just on pure skill and it was still like
that non response to that I enjoyed
playing just gonna fit perfectly from
the moment he started playing Canadian
was determined to become the best
regardless of whether the game would
ever become a full-fledged eSport so
wasn't really a decision it was like I
said I've always been competitive so
like I just tried to compete I didn't
know if the game would blow up I didn't
know I could do it for a living anything
like that it was just like I played it
and there was like free tournaments on
the game and I literally just wanted to
play just like for bragging rights even
with the announcement of Pro League in
January 2016
Canadian decided that the time had come
to dedicate his life to siege the timing
was not opportune given that he just
started a degree in civil engineering
but Canadian couldn't shy away from his
competitive nature so I took time off
school and just kind of put all my time
into it and just wanted to see what
happened so like pretty much as soon as
pro league actually started I went
all-out
and just went both arms in preparation
for pro league which was slated to kick
off in March 2016
Canadian started competing in ESL go4
our six events with a roster entitled
art of execution from there he moved to
mythic eSports with whom he made his pro
league debut
after putting on a middling performance
in season one Canadian join team orbit
who managed to swing a second-place
finish in the season 2 finals this is
looking dangerously close to young
disaffected one more win in the wake of
orbit success Canadian joint
biggity-boom Bob a roster of his own
making who come season 3 took on the
name continuum and it was with that
roster that Canadian finally got the
chance to do what he did best lead I
think he got his dream master and he got
to do what he wanted with it and that's
why it is such a super team not just
because a Canadian of course they
everybody else on that roster as well
but I think he got to execute his vision
with that game continuum went on to
finish second in the third season of
North American Pro League who faced off
against playing ducks in one of the most
exhilarating finals in siege history if
a new Canadian is now up top two black
kids on this floor
if Canadian can kill this black beard
before he gets around this corner black
weeds on his turf he doesn't see him can
you pigs over the top kills a thermite
charge but there will fall one throw my
charge for Canadian that series went the
full three maps and by the end of the
third both teams had amassed five points
of peace they were squared up for one
final round
winner take all even as continuum found
themselves staring down the barrel of a
5v3
they refused to give up under Canadians
leadership they prevailed VP in the top
of this decade you can see the gun me
Pete taken out of it above my neck cross
it's 1 V 2 4 LM this is gonna be the
deciding factor continuum can't find him
but there's a second retro tonic getting
more than enough time to diffuse
continuum on the first North American
team to win rainbow 6 prolene holy Sh
wall
after winning pro league continuum were
invited to compete in sieges first
official Ubisoft hosted World
Championship the six Invitational where
continuum and we are the defending
Rainbow six siege world champions we're
here to defend our title and become the
first real world champions of this game
heading into the tournament Canadian had
already solidified himself as sieges
single most resourceful player he's
really aggressive he's a credible shot
he's so flexible on what he can play
it's just that kind of diversity as how
he can play that makes him such a
special player in addition to proving
that he was capable of being both a
top-tier Fragger and inspiring in-game
leader he became known for his ability
to id8 and implement a wide array of
counter strats if you ever did the same
strap twice you lose that's always been
the deal with Evy if Troy gets an idea
of what it is you're gonna be doing and
you do the same next round he already
has a plan that you just can't be
Canadian value Lee led his team to the
grand final matchup against era eternity
a North American underdog who'd entered
through the qualifier era did manage to
swing a map in their favor but
Continuum's Canadian crafted counter
stradun was simply too much for them to
handle snake will push his way in is it
tucked in the corner ten seconds to go
comes on her round loses the fight the
Canadian once ago at avian alert and he
dropped down particular York world
champions
[Applause]
from the moment he first encountered
siege Canadian had thought of nothing
but becoming the best and at the game's
first ever World Championship he
achieved just that and how does that
feel I don't really have any words I
just really want to pick up this hammer
then you should pick up this hammer go
get it
[Applause]
[Music]
the question was whether he'd ever be
able to do it again following their
victory at the inaugural Invitational
continuum fell into the most
inexplicable of slumps they have to play
this perfectly but they already have 10
seconds they can't just run away from
him in Hong Kong they are gonna fight
you he doesn't need the ten seconds he's
a kill and it's it and it's game
continue of your world champions are
done in this season they're burning and
elevate to advance the playoffs in fact
it wasn't until the third season that
they were able to secure a first-place
finish to bo3 establish their regional
dominance and qualified for the Pro
League finals and the upcoming
Invitational slow and steady will win
this race NBK takes down one it's only
easily left as vertical note now upright
young answers and it's all on vertical
he'll go for one but nvk lays in wait
finishes it off and CTM is back they
will go to the invitational and they are
your number one seed heading into South
Paulo following their resurgence
Canadian and his teammates were picked
up by legendary North American eSports
organization evil geniuses in what was
undoubtedly a perfect fit it was
definitely a big deal to me it meant a
lot to me to see that eg kind of saw me
and my team what they saw in these other
other players and teams upon reaching
the pro league finals in South Paolo
however eg were once again faced with a
disappointing result luck would have it
that eg would have faced the recently
dominant hence eSports in the very first
round the playoffs
two titans going to bed somebody's gonna
be really upset no matter who goes the
community loses no matter what no matter
who behind canto flanking he takes out
MBK it's a double pressure hold Bootsy
takes out Canadian against neck rocks -
it's just BC he'll have to contend is
canto comes in and that's takes map
number one will they be able to finish
him off Wilke provides covering fire but
young refracts and that's a one-for-one
his neck rocks finally gets the mountain
down
and now evil genius only has two more to
go to close this one out
make that one as Canadian finish this up
on shot I can't tell rushes in
he gets Canadian but neck rocks finishes
it off and we're going over time and
despite fighting tooth and nail
Canadian squad couldn't help but put up
a middling v six finish at the second
most important tournament of the year
and there's only one left
it's just BC it's good break the spell
they could make it to the semi-finals
canto goes down BC still got more to go
but Bernard finishes it and axe moves to
the semi-finals but with the
invitational right around the corner
they couldn't afford to dwell on it
eg had had a rough year but they were
still regarded as juggernauts everyone
from the fans to the community to the
casters analysts and players were
hopeful that with Canadian at the helm
the defending champions were bound to
perform and perform they did every
single member of eg above the site right
now cameraman out to lunch Canadian
takes them go hon Astro stepping in one
of Young's vines that will be a
consistent damage to him as he pulls the
needle out right by the bomb and looks
to slip the diffuser landing cameraman
pushes up wins a fight on that Canadian
FAK
he is thirty Seconds to stop him from
successfully gonna get a fuse off but in
the midst of it is Canadian they'll hold
long angles as easily gets eliminated
evil geniuses welcome to your grand
final on the back of Canadians tenacity
eg grinded their way to the grand finals
and it was there when he was one series
away from defending his World
Championship the Canadian had his first
significant encounter with Penta and an
eloquent innocuous little Viking by the
name of Penghu I never thought in my
wildest far but now the best teams in
the world most feared and I've been
fortunate and individuals who make world
records or the moments that will go down
a history of the game but I'm only as
good as my last game that's what drives
me to keep going the matchup that ensued
between Penta a super team who'd spent
the year dominating the European pro
league and the unlikely underdog that
was Evil Geniuses has since been
declared the greatest series in sieges
history it's always frightening when
Penghu is left in a 1v3 because he can
absolutely clutch around for his team
but not today
eg says don't think you met one goes to
them by a score of five to two and the
crowd very happy about that result neck
rocks inching up so close one goes down
Penghu doesn't look sees the mute neck
lock the canadian it's five to four eg
and neck rock still a contestant
beware of the championship
in a series in which they were supposed
to get crushed
eg were sitting on a two-game advantage
the community was stunned I was shocked
that evil geniuses found themselves in a
position when they were up to oh and I
thought to myself while I was casting I
was like I didn't really come into this
match thinking that they could do it and
at that moment I was like they can
probably pull this off Penta was down
but as eg were about to find out they
were far from out there was all sorts of
new strategies that they brought out
which kind of frustrated me because once
we went up to O Wentz on the third map
and it was like one of our best maps at
the time it was actually a map that they
didn't play often but they pulled out
like this Montaigne strategy that we had
never seen before and that was a very
good play their neck rocks distracted
fabien taking nvk the second time around
this Manti push that we see from Penta
is absolutely crushing eg now Canadian
once again in a situation and basically
like completely destroyed us because
we'd had no idea how to react to it
so one before taken down to next no
health he'll take Goga but he now has a
shield in his way very difficult with
only one bill to eliminate amante but
Penta takes their first map we're gonna
go bang next up what a good push and a
great strategy for them to be able to
close out cafe by the time the fifth and
final map against Penta came around it
was clear that eg had come apart at the
seams and you still under pressure will
be shut up from two angles in just a
moment pain to water Donald and BK
he gets two
advantage for eg goes away neck cracks
just needs to fight Bobby who will hold
on that crux no diffuser pets on that
point from but then out of nowhere EG
began to rally how effectively is Penghu
going to be able to cover that fire he
gets BC can paint you keep going he's
look so good paint you with neck rocks
takes it down don't get the diffuser
pets are not taking this just yet it's
inside of theater and he's gonna have a
lot of bodies to fight three C's be
steel Wow eg two in a row little back to
defense could we have overtime
ten seconds has fallen off of the clock
he moves towards the main door there is
barbed wire in there that will let AG
know you can see there's only one inside
it's the mirror of BC can he return
after winning three consecutive rounds
eg had managed to swing the momentum
back in their favor
he was looking more and more like they
might take the series in overtime to
each Canadian has a tiny portion to help
he holds that diffuser Hangu down Bobby
and all alone in theatres he sticks the
diffuser waits for the audio kid young
will need to cover there is a c4 from
Fabian he Prime's it Canadian falls off
he goes down young will need to get him
he has only 10 seconds and he enters
they will be in a standoff can he get
the Valkyrie two seconds young pushes up
running out of time neither get it Penta
hold on
that's point pet sock having lost the
first round of OT to an unfortunate miss
play eg faced match point for the second
time in the series the following round
was quick vicious and ultimately saw eg
come ahead in a 2v1 post plant situation
all they had to do was secure one last
kill defuse and pushed the series to a
deciding round but Pangu had other plans
now look to push together the diffuser
in a position where they'll have to see
when the hip on it goes through one will
cover the doorway
for Evil Geniuses their community of
fans and sieges North American player
base at large the choke against Penta
was heartbreaking but for Canadian it
was downright devastating a loss that he
would never forget like I know I the
invitational when I was talking to a
Amara when you when you guys lost and
then you and you took some time before
you came out to see me and he went back
and got ya to make sure you were okay
yeah
yeah they're good guys
following the brutal loss Canadian set
his sights on one thing beating Penta we
definitely want revenge on Penta after
losing them as far as like the next
specific goal we started to really
buckle down and focus on practicing a
lot more for the beginning of the season
I kind of I'm obsessive over it I don't
know it's just I guess my competitive
nature come to Paris major in August
Canadian had developed something of a
reputation he was without question one
of sieges single most iconic players a
barrell obsessive competitor who was
indescribably serious about winning and
at the same time one does those moment
of victory it feels like everything is
controlled by this player and at the
moments of victory the moment the winner
around the clutch around you see him
getting like absolutely pumped you see
mister he's moved like let's go so
there's a something where like he's a
true true competitor like in the truest
sense in fact and often felt as if
Canadian took winning a little too
seriously
I think he's outspoken Canadian is
extremely outspoken he's passionate he's
funny you know sometimes he gets caught
up in the moment and sometimes those
emotions
I think manifests themselves in ways
that don't necessarily endear you to the
fans but he's a controversial and a
striking figure that's really it and yet
for Penghu Canadiens greatest rival does
it become a point of admiration so we
call him the wu try because it goes when
you watched roy you feel the intensity
you feel the passion a hundred percent
there was no question canadian was as
dedicated as they come and his
investment in the game wasn't just
physical mental or professional it was
spiritual I didn't get lucky like came
across something like seein just how
drastic of a change that was that kind
of lightbulb moment words like I really
like this I'm gonna make this my passion
and eventually my career the Paris major
marked the first you be stopped hosted
event that wasn't the Invitational and
after making it all the way to the grand
finals Canadian was determined to
finally come out on top same as last
time we got absolutely [ __ ] nothing
to lose they have everything in the
world to lose that number one spot right
best in the world that's ours tonight
but Penta who are now playing as g2
eSports had gotten even stronger will
have to retake against the a she finds
to kill Encanto does have the stim
pistol to boost himself up as he finds
the back of the head of baby the go g2
will tell EJ as map number one with a
six to score line will go the way of our
European squad of g2 eSports eg dropped
round after round map after map until
finally are you close to getting the
victory any votes down
we'll take the win and for one more
we'll take the second major tournament
of the year six Invitational 2018
one up by Europe g2 spearheading a push
for European rainbow succeed
for the second time in a row Canadian
had lost a major grand final to Pangu
the difference is that this time it had
been a slaughter
after Paris I was really frustrated with
myself I think that was like the worst
individual performance I had Pangu said
it in interviews before he said like
that he like ran into me in the lobby
that day he said like I didn't seem like
myself as the captain an in-game layer
no matter how frustrated I am with how
I'm playing I need to bring that energy
into my team because it affects all of
them if I'm different I did feel like I
kind of let the team down in that sense
following Paris Canadian became even
more determined to win after a number of
roster changes Canadian prepared to face
g2 at the pro league season eight finals
in Rio we have potential matchup against
them in the semi-finals obviously we
play fnatic first Gotcha will scatter
like all the other teams as well to have
them but we're really trying to kind of
close the gap with g2 and pass them up
but first they had to go through fnatic
a team who recently had one of their
players hospitalized magnetised
unexpectedly brought treats it got
operated on he's all good but he
couldn't get here in dizzle their coach
Lee's plan and then the unthinkable
happened oh no don't for it's right out
but it gets shot right in the in the air
but not equal take the
now in the quarter files with their
coach playing the big problem is not eat
cheese opponents its AG's mindset it's
always a game it's not EG g - e -
whatever it's EG versus EDP after
dropping the first map EG were put into
a do-or-die situation the problem was
that fnatic had nothing to lose and they
were playing like it shots almost
connecting to mesas he is back on that
foot 12 again there we go fnatic closer
in closer he's still on the outside the
elbow 12 less man alive is neck cross
this MV K's on the G with a 2-0 magnet
you're not coming back after this one
with one player in the hospital and
their coach playing as a substitute
fnatic cheese their way to a 2-0 victory
over the second best team in the world
no matter what when you show up to a
match the team you're playing against is
gonna do something that you're not used
to and we can't make the excuse like oh
they wouldn't do that in a match or Oh
like that doesn't work normally
right after the match actually like I
said to my team I was like I don't want
you here anyone make that excuse ever
again like we just lost a major lane
event because of that excuse g2 went on
to take first and for the first time
since they're faded rivalry began
Pangos victory didn't need to entail
Canadians defeat in fact it was after
Canadians quarterfinal loss that Pangu
began to look upon him with the worst
possible thing pity and extremely happy
that we didn't face them this time
around had to break his heart again or
he would have to break mine again it
just at some point you can fix the
damage that's been done and I would like
you know how our careers to continue it
out and facing each other all the time
but with the invitational in three
months people still hope that Canadian
could carry his team to a glorious
result his streak of second-place
finishes got so bad that eg even fell
short of first at US Nationals
Ubisoft all-americans supplication to
pro league but eg were making strides
with their new lineup and fans were
hopeful after all there had never been
an invitational or major final in which
Canadian wasn't a participant and as
soon as the 2019 Invitational kicked off
it became clear that Iggy's hard work
had paid off they finished first in
their group having achieved the exact
same record as g2 and were considered
favourites going into the playoffs
Iggy's first matchup was against team
reciprocity a North American underdog
who eg had screamed on many occasions
the way that you're going into this if
you're a reciprocity player is that no
matter what you're at a disadvantage
heading into this just simply because
that the map pool is not developed
enough at least on paper and I think
that I completely agree with you Oregon
would have been a better bet but Bank is
what we'll go to and I think that it'll
have to be a miracle to see reciprocity
take map number one and as soon as the
series kicked off that expectation
became a reality thinks better of it is
the diffuser is left and now he'll
finally commit to going down the hallway
Gio here is really coming playing it's
safe spot say hit the deck try and keep
the holes at all it takes is one peek
from
that's map one of the ports evil
geniuses one map away Roley match
against g2 this time in the semi-finals
Iggy's dominance extended well into map
to where they put themselves in a prime
position to face off against g2 in the
next round more drones coming out as
maybe well isolate and finish off waxing
its Fox they alone a 1v5 insurmountable
task nvk will shut it down retaking the
lead our evil geniuses two rounds away
from the semi-finals and then slowly but
surely the tides started to turn thanks
said the GU - he slowly makes its way up
and he'll take down retro free fires
into the road sleep of Fox late will
drop neck rocks and then BK on the
flanks guys another one it's all up to
young turning and twisting inside of the
site in the midst of smokey got to on
its main stair team falls into his
demise and reciprocity will equalize
once again it's a 5/5 game in a
crossfire now from the other side of the
bar four seconds left and ladies and
gentlemen we are going to map three
between reciprocity and Evil Geniuses
from this point on eg found themselves
playing from behind they've gone from
being two points away from sending
reciprocity home to being on the brink
of defeat it's Canadian against skies
with diffuser down key and hopping
straight on the defusion skies Boston
out the window and you couldn't get off
he hears the window breaking free fires
connected on the shoulder for just a
moment and now Canadian again attempting
to stick two seconds one second turn to
the corner skies will shut it down
reciprocity match points series points
so it was fitting that the final round
came down to a 1v3 between canadian and
the remaining members of reciprocity
it's a 1v3 Canadian to keep his team
alive in the biggest tournament in the
world turning the corner he grabs one on
the mark trying to go in for two against
Fox hey aunty Allah will take his two
bullets close right through the diigolet
Eagles are down 1v1 against laxing
accion Charm City eliminate evil
geniuses aye
this day was done
and the quarters like this and a big
stage reciprocity almost gave out rounds
ooh
because that is what I'm doing wondering
what just happened
the nightmare had been realized for the
first time in his career
Canadian had failed to make the grand
finals of an invitational a finals in
which g2 would trounced their opponents
and secured their third consecutive
major title it seems as if there's more
riding on the success of Canadians each
career than meets the eye this is a guy
who was born to be a professional
athlete who might very well have made it
into the NHL or MLB had it not been for
his head injuries and it seems as if
every time he wins or loses it's with
that in mind look at this lumber tonight
Wow
you taking that home with you that's a
keeper free no okay okay cool but it's
also clear that Canadian isn't the kind
of guy to give up on trying to become
the best to give up on himself I do
think I detect a new kind of level of
Canadian coming I think there's a new
slightly not a slightly wiser not to say
he isn't already wise but just lightly
he's gonna learn from these experiences
I think he's always gonna be a great
player but I think he's gonna there's
gonna be an extra level to him to come
back from these defeats that way perhaps
there's a lot of talk in eSports about
certain players being true competitors
but there's no question that Canadian
takes labels like that to a whole other
level he's one of those few players for
whom the best is never too much trouble
he's a good what he called a good role
model for people that want to get into
these balls right
the dedication that they show and that's
both for Canadian and then for every
other top contender to be honest come
the season 9 finals in Milan he proved
that eg were still one of the best teams
in the world and despite their
catastrophic choke against Empire and
then be cable watch's cheer goes for the
plan the sound queue will give Tim the
information only takes what doubt will
rise as you crown a new champion here in
the lon
an edition of Dan to this team proves to
be what's needed and this miracle
comeback from Evil Geniuses
will be all but a dream Empire are your
season nine champions an absolute
heartbreaker they've got that feeling
Michael at least I did that we were
looking at an opportunity ago
or time it sure did feel like we were
back at the 16 potential in 2018 oh yeah
with eg storming back after finding
themselves down by such a number one
thing did become clear
there is another championship with
Canadians name written all over it
he just hasn't found it yet but with
every heartbreak
this is gonna be Evil Geniuses going
home neck cracks rotating but it's not
gonna be for anything the Giants said
Evil Geniuses packing for the first time
and a group stage at a major he only
gets hungrier he's wanted nothing more
than to lift that hammer since the day
they made him put it down and now that
he's found a new home on Space Station
gaming he won't rest until he does
[Music]
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell for unique
bite-sized videos you will find anywhere
else hit up our Instagram Twitter and
Facebook pages